from Rachel in Texas I'm confused on how
to begin baby step 2 if we are behind
how do we get ahead meaning our monthly
income will not cover all expenses with
mortgage due at the beginning of the
month it puts us behind and lacking the
money we need to get through the
remainder of the month do I skip credit
card payments just to get ahead ok
Rachel before you start the baby steps
at all your budget has to balance the
baby steps is what you do with extra
money you can find in your budget you
not only don't have extra money you are
short each month is what you're saying
you're saying your budget has more money
going out than you have coming in you're
not Congress that has to change how are
we going to change it well you have to
increase your income and decrease your
outgo I see a part-time job in your
all's future or 2 or 6 I also see you
selling something with payments on it
because it's killing you
yeah I see you having a big garage sale
and knocking out a few of your smaller
credit cards with that money I think
what you've got to do is you have to get
current before you start talking about
the baby steps you're not on baby step 2
if you're not current because you
shouldn't have $1,000 in the bank if
you're not current you have to get
current first now are you padding to
some of the categories in the budget I
don't know your every dollar app will
help you with that and here's the thing
every dollar app has all kinds of blanks
in it to prompt you to not forget
something that you're really going to
spend in other words make a budget that
is actually real that you can really use
but no one but God has enough money to
put something in every single blank in
the every dollar app and so it's not
designed for you - yeah there's no
mandatory thing you have to put
something in every blank all you have to
do is give every dollar of your
in come an assignment every dollar a
name thus the name every dollar for your
every dollar budgeting app it takes
about 10 minutes to set it up it's
completely free to use the app and you
can put it on your phone or on your
desktop so that's how you do that stuff
now then once you've done that if you've
base if you cover your payments and your
basic necessities of life food clothing
transportation car gasoline that kind of
thing and you're still coming up short
then you have to take on an extra job
and you have to sell something that's
got payments on it both to get the logs
am busted through because you've got to
get on the upside to where there's more
money coming in than going out in order
to make progress it's not optional
that's the only way you can do this
you're not in Congress so hope that
helps you it's a good question
thanks for writing it in to us for our
question of the day for blinds.com